grünes licht für achterbahnen und
karussells deutschland freizeitparks
haben wieder auf und die fans von
rasanten fahrten kommen endlich wieder
auf ihre kosten
man kann die freude förmlich spüren bei
den menschen die hier herein strömen
zehntausend besucher werden hier heute
erwartet der europa park ist ein
besuchermagnet hier können die menschen
ihren hunger nach nervenkitzel nach
action nach familienspaß endlich wieder
stillen
trotz kroner die gesichter am eingang
strahlen und die besucher fügen sich
gerne den auflagen
ja wir wollten uns hier zu sein weil wir
haben schon vor einem jahr gebucht und
jetzt durch die kronenzeitung geschichte
haben wir gezittert und gebangt ob wir
hinfahren dürfen wunderbar nicht viel
los und super wetter zum glück kam nach
tickets gekriegt also ich freue mich
dass es endlich wieder losgeht
ich denke auch die parkbetreiber sind
gut vorbereitet und wenn die gäste auf
ein bisschen mitmachen
gegen 50 schöner tag und wer bekommen
sonst schon von einer rollstuhl für die
hände desinfiziert
wenn sie dann nehmen sie rücksicht
aufeinander halten sie sich an jene und
abstandsregelungen dh in den restaurants
und fahrgeschäften ist die maske pflicht
genauso wie abstand halten
jede zweite reihe bleibt leer gehört
verstanden loske die flotte fahrt
all das aber cool es macht mir viel spaß
es hat ein bisschen ungewöhnlich da was
geht ganz gut als musterstadt der
hinterhof muss ich immer festhalten ohne
corona kommen an tagen wie diesen bis zu
50.000 leute in dem park europaweit
übrigens der zweitgrößte nach disneyland
paris
jetzt ist nur ein fünftel davon drin
dennoch ist der chef zufrieden
das sind wirklich glücklich dass die
gäste sich so fallen wie wir uns
gewünscht haben theoretisch vor gesetzt
haben und vor allem was schönes sondern
unglaublich viel freude mit den kindern
wieder einmal gemeinsam was zu nehmen
dass wir dazu beitragen das macht man
natürlich besonders heute schon bald
kann man sich hier sogar per app
kontrollieren ob mit dem abstand auch
alles stimmt gewischt und geschrubbt
wird hier den ganzen tag desinfizieren
nicht nur zur sicherheit der gäste
es fühlt sich aktuell an wie ein ganz
neuer job das ist halt viel mehr
augenmerk auf die hygiene darauf dass
sie sicher gestellt ist dass die gäste
sich nicht anstecken uns aneinander dass
wir mitarbeiter aber auch geschützt sind
ja und wer hier ganz sicher gehen will
der darf kalte duschen verschiedene
attraktionen genießen
und mancher kommt hier aus dem dauert
vilsen nicht mehr heraus trotz
eingeschränkten verfügungs programm man
da fahren man darf feiern man darf essen
und trinken genießen das einzige auf was
die besucher hier verzichten müssen das
den schoß
die auflagen im europa-park gelten bis
auf weiteres nur ein fünftel der
besucher so lange muss man im internet
beim run auf die eintrittskarten schnell
sein
das nagelneue spaßbad samt hotel für 200
millionen euro hat noch geschlossen es
geht bergauf seit 8 uhr 30 fahren die
seilbahnen wieder hier an der zugspitze
allerdings auch beim gipfelsturm gilt es
gibt anti corona hygieneregeln
allen voran maske aufsetzen das mit den
ein meter fünfzig abstand haben sie
schon verinnerlicht jetzt 13 die
sehnsucht rauf auf den berg
wir konnten gar nicht mehr skifahren
furchtbare in zugs erscheinungen und
jetzt will man wenigstens schauen oben
noch alle steht zweite wohnt sie meister
oben wir haben ein jahres was alle und
haben gemeint ist wenn wir ganz früh da
sind dann sind wir vielleicht auch die
ersten die gondel fährt bis auf weiteres
mit verringerter kapazität statt 120
sind nur noch 40 passagiere pro fahrt
erlaubt wie angenehm für einen platz in
der ersten reihe muss keiner drängeln
sondern auch nicht auf der gipfel
terrasse dann maske herunter und
genießen die wolken verhängen den großen
panorama blick egal hauptsache urlaub
hauptsache berg wir haben alle urlaub
zusammen genommen dass man am
pfingstwochenende irgendwo überhaupt
hinfahren können da haben wir trinken
oder erst an der steller schön wieder
mal was unternehmen und dann zieht es zu
der nebel kommt der grenzübergang zu
österreich ist noch immer geschlossen
auf der zugspitze und das bleibt auch
noch mindestens zwei wochen so die
bayern profitieren davon dass die
deutschen im eigenen land bleiben hier
sagt man dazu
urlaub doch am ende klappt für einige
wenige sogar der aufstieg zum
gipfelkreuz social dating ist hier heute
kein problem
endlich fährt die weiße flotte wieder
wir haben hier in dresden mit neuen
raddampfern die größte und auch die
älteste raddampferflotte der welt das
ist ein kulturgut das zu dresden mit
dazu führt und wir schauen uns jetzt mal
von der elbe aus die schöne umgebung an
die fahrt startet das einmalige panorama
der altstadt im hintergrund die dresden
unser raddampfer ist übrigens der erste
in europa der nach corinna wieder raus
fährt auch hier wurden die sitzplätze um
die hälfte reduziert 200 passagiere
finden platz mit abstand und wenn sie
unterwegs sind an bord mit maske
wunderbares war so stimmt das erste mal
wieder sehr schön
dresden ist eine der schönsten städte
die wir haben und wenn man so die
altstadt sieht traumhaft willkommen von
weiter weg und finde es einfach super
als erster wieder aufwärts zeigen und
wir genießen es einfach
wir sind auf schlösser fahrt schön ist
so weit das auge reicht die dresdner
wein werde
hier hat sich von schiller wohl gefühlt
als er anderen carlos und der ode an die
freude schrieb die brücke vorne ist das
blaue wunder eine sich seit fast 130
jahren selbst tragende stahlkonstruktion
kapitän andreas weber hat vor über 30
jahren bei der weißen flotte angeheuert
eine fahrt auf einem historischen
raddampfer entschleunigt ungemein
es ist wie eine kleine zeitreise und
doch so notwendig in dieser hektischen
gegenwart seit 184 jahren schippert die
weiße flotte über die elbe wegen corona
muss sie gerade wieder mal ums überleben
kämpfen
dresden ohne seine dampf das ist schwer
vorstellbar vor uns liegt will jetzt die
letzte station lustschloss von august
dem starken
ja und das schönste das kommt eigentlich
erst noch nämlich hinter uns da liegt
die sächsische schweiz da müssen sie
sich dann allerdings ein paar tage mehr
zeit nehmen
wir hoffen dass im juni die weiße flotte
auch wieder die sächsische schweiz
anfangen kann
mein tipp wäre sommerurlaub in sachsen
die sächsische schweiz ist eines der
beliebtesten ausflugsziele über die
feiertage die besucher sehen sich alle
nach entspannung und ablenkung und
treffen dann doch auch viel mehr
gleichgesinnte als manchen lieb ist
wir sind extra fries los aber ja die
leute denken glaube ich alles so wie ich
und komm halt schon die sächsische
schweiz und genießen das wetter und die
tolle gegend laufen und dann werden wir
ein bisschen ruhe finden und so weiter
richtung see laufen oder an
aussichtspunkten wieder bastei konnte
von abstandsregeln keine rede sein
zu groß die sehnsucht der menschen raus
in die natur zu gehen und dafür auch
gleich noch ein paar urlaubstage an die
feiertage dranzuhängen
die ranger des nationalparks erzählen
uns dass die sächsische schweiz seit
tagen von besuchern förmlich überrannt
wird und ein ende ist nicht in sicht
in den hotels und herbergen sind laut
betreiber für die nächsten monate so gut
wie ausgebucht
schlendern shoppen sonne tanken nach
zwei monaten zwangspause ist die
ferieninsel usedom wieder geöffnet für
touristen aus ganz deutschland wie die
meisten zieht es doch nicht erst mal an
den strand frische ostseeluft lässt sich
zb hier in ahlbeck genießen
ich bin erstaunt wie lehrers ist klar
nachvollziehbar nachdem beschränkung
aber ist gut super wir wollten ja schon
vorher fahren und damit hatte sich das
erledigt
aber jetzt hier zu sein ist natürlich
himmlisch und ist nicht mehr gut
eingeschenkt
man kann ein bisschen freier losen und
na ja also das schön aufatmen nicht nur
bei den gästen sondern auch bei den
astronomen restaurantbetreiber andere
dunkel kann sein lokal endlich wieder
aufmachen was haben sie denn gut dass
welche spezialitäten haben sie bei sich
im haus
wir sind natürlich spezialisiert auf
osten frisch nach wie vor und wir haben
natürlich tolle sachen wie als spezielle
zehn jahren zb geräuchert als willi
albers nach omas rezept und ganz neu
haben wir uns auch noch drauf mal passt
und die serviert mir der chef persönlich
die korona pause hat der gelernte koch
genutzt um neue rezepte zu kreieren eine
mischung aus usedomer ein und usedom
marquise der gewinn wurde und das ganze
wurde dann ähnlich wie bei der carbonara
es los auf usedom narrisch quasi um die
münster gut gestärkt mache ich mich auf
und fahre zur westküste der insel an das
achterwasser
segellehrer jörg butt startet hier
wieder mit dem unterricht
ich habe mich sehr gefreut vor paar
tagen hat für die erste serie schulung
gemacht haben es war schon schön
seit knapp 30 jahren bringt der
gebürtige berliner hier schülern wie mir
den wassersport näher
es ist der perfekte ort dafür sagt er
gerade zum lernen es ist schön zum
windsurfen kitesurfen weil du hast den
riesigen flachwasserbereich zum segeln
auch kein schiffsverkehr keinen keinen
bade sowie wir stören können beide
verkehr oder so insofern das ist ein
tolles segelrevier das wasser vor der
tür haben auch gute und kühler
die beiden vermieten ferienwohnungen im
kaiserbad heringsdorf den chor oder
bedingten lockdown der insel haben sie
in einem tagebuch festgehalten
es war schon gespenst sich und surreal
und von daher
es war wirklich eine erfahrung aber sie
hätten sich so lange sein müssen
veränderten abstands und hygieneregeln
was müssen sie da jetzt bei der
vermietung ihrer ferienwohnung besonders
beachten zum üblichen reinigen kommt hat
jetzt durch die vorschriften dazu dass
man so häufig berührte kontaktflächen
desinfiziert dass ein bisschen mehr
aufwand aber auch das spiel sich ein
ich denke sind weiter da wir klopfen mal
an seit montag sind die ferienwohnungen
der kühlers wieder vermietet anke hoppe
und dem mann udo sind stammgäste aus
eisenach sie konnten es kaum erwarten
auf die insel zu reisen
das wird auch hat bis jetzt auch
mitgespielt also wir sind vollauf
zufrieden
was haben sie denn schon alles gemacht
wir fahren jeden tag so um die 40 kilo
fahrrad ein wunderbares fahrradweg es
ist den wir gehen da am strand spazieren
zweimal war schön und wir machen jeden
morgen ein 3000 meter lauf
aber usedom ist nicht nur für
sportbegeisterte interessant in bansin
gibt es exotisches zu entdecken
tierpflegerin eva morgenstern kümmert
sich um die seltenen gold kopf löwen
äffchen im freigehege des tropen zoos
darf ich ihr bei der dritte rung helfen
es ist natürlich schön wenn man ein
faible für tiere hat nach da kann man
sich nicht wünschen
weil dann ist ständig mit dem zusammen
sie tun auch wenn mappus auf arbeitet
kommt und habe nicht die richtige laune
das dauerte keine viertelstunde dann
dann ist man wieder dicke derweil die in
so viel freude bereiten freude bereiten
die tiere auch den kindern so jetzt
wieder besuchen
diese art von kontakt unterscheidet uns
von anderen suchen und direkten kontakt
mit den leuten mit dem publikum
egal ob songs restaurants oder
ferienwohnungen auf usedom sind die die
was zu bieten haben froh ihre gäste
wieder begrüßen zu können und auch für
besucher wie mich ist es ein genuss
[Musik]